[Music]
for missiles you can carry on your
shoulders to attack drones these are
some of ukraine's smaller weapons and
they've been effective at fighting
russia's bigger and more powerful arms
military strategists say these lighter
tools can help an underdog army become
more like a porcupine the porcupine
strategy is really when a smaller
military tries to defend itself from a
larger military which is the attacker
and it uses lots of smaller weapons
this strategy has inspired taiwan and
even its president to rethink how to
defend itself against a much larger
adversary china beijing sees taiwan as
part of its territory
and as the possibility of an armed
conflict around the island has escalated
taipei is taking clues from ukraine to
prepare to fight china's powerful army
[Music]
for several decades taiwan has favored
expensive gear like fighter jets
helicopters and tanks to prepare for a
possible war with china
and this threat has become heightened as
tensions have soared to the highest
point over taiwan in more than two
decades
after u.s house speaker nancy pelosi
visited taipei beijing began days of
military exercises that encircled the
island
launching rocket and ballistic missiles
and sending navy ships and warplanes
nearby
defense analysts say if there were an
actual invasion taiwan alone wouldn't be
able to ward off china because its
big-ticket weapons would be quickly
destroyed by a more powerful arsenal
and taiwan has far fewer soldiers
compared with its neighbor which has the
world's largest military by active
personnel given the disadvantages that's
where the so-called porcupine
capabilities come in much like the
animal it tries to inflict so much pain
on the large arrival
that it stops the attacker
and one way to inflict a lot of pain
these handheld anti-tank and
anti-aircraft equipment used by
individual soldiers since the start of
the war in ukraine the us has sent
thousands of stinger and javelin
missiles to the battlefield
and these weapons are particularly
useful for smaller militaries because
they're able to have an outsized impact
on their rival the russians have been
using lots of large invasion forces
using tanks and planes and ukrainians
have been able to fight back by using
these smaller weapons and using them
very effectively to destroy large
targets so far hundreds of russian tanks
and aircraft have been destroyed since
the war broke out in february according
to an open source website that tracks
military equipment losses
and that success has driven some
taiwanese leaders including the
president to embrace these types of
anti-tank and anti-aircraft weapons
earlier this year taiwan's legislature
also approved a motion to conduct more
training possibly involving portable
missiles like the javelin and stinger
but those handheld missiles have
limitations because they only have an
operating range of about two and a half
miles
[Music]
that's why taiwan like ukraine is also
getting longer range weapons like these
mobile rocket launchers called haimars
in ukraine they've allowed the army to
reach beyond russia's front line sending
missiles up to 53 miles away
in 2020 the us approved the first sale
of the weapon to taiwan and the island's
defense ministry said it's looking to
buy more of them
another relatively small weapon that can
impose heavy losses from very far away
the attack drone so attack drones can be
very useful for smaller militaries
because it enables them to do
significant damage behind enemy lines
ukrainians have been destroying russian
tanks convoys that have been coming into
the country the attack drones have also
been effective at hitting russia's navy
in may ukraine released footage of what
it said were drones hitting two russian
vessels in the black sea russia didn't
comment on the ukrainian claim
this type of sea based assault could
happen in taiwan since military experts
say a chinese invasion would involve a
lot of ships coming over the taiwan
street so the island has been developing
its own indigenous drones like this one
the u.s has also agreed to sell some
drones and taiwanese lawmakers have been
pushing to purchase four of them
taiwan's government isn't just preparing
weapons
its citizens are also taking action so
some people are picking up shooting
lessons just like the ukrainians and
rallying this type of public support is
also an important part of the porcupine
strategy
in ukraine things didn't go as quickly
as the russians thought they would
one of the reasons for that is the
motivation and the
willingness of the ukrainian population
to take up arms and to
defend their country
so to prepare its citizens for a war
taiwan's defense ministry is debating
plans to extend military conscription
for up to a year one two or three
and a survey found that more than 70 of
adults are in favor of a longer service
time
while taiwan can learn a lot from
ukraine's experience there are unique
challenges ukraine borders other
countries and that makes it possible for
its troops to continue receiving a
steady flow of weapons and supplies but
taiwan is an island and there may be
difficulties
if there is a chinese invasion for
taiwan to receive weapons from other
countries particularly if the chinese
form a blockade around the island so it
needs to have large stockpiles ready for
a conflict
so building that stock has become a
priority this year the government
pledged an extra 8.7 billion dollars for
military equipment the u.s which has
promised to help taiwan defend itself
has been selling military gear to taipei
for decades and after pelosi's visit
there she said america wouldn't abandon
its commitment to the island we work
together for the security of taiwan
china's national defense ministry didn't
respond to a request for comment about
taiwan's military buildup but taiwan
isn't the only one keeping a close eye
on the war in ukraine military experts
say china is taking notes too and one of
those would be that if you are going to
try and take over one of your neighbors
you need to use overwhelming force
and that's been showcased during its
life fire drills showing its ability to
effectively blockay taiwan if taiwan is
faced with one of the world's most
powerful conventional militaries coming
at you with everything
that's a very difficult challenge